que damien meslot merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur christophe sirugue secrétaire
d'état chargé de l'industrie auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur le ministre le 7 septembre
dernier la direction d'alstom annoncé la
fermeture du site alstom de belfort
voulant mettre fin sans 37 ans
d'histoire industrielle dans notre ville
la forte mobilisation des élus des
salariés des organisations syndicales et
de la population a permis de défendre ce
site historique
nous vous avons rencontré à plusieurs
reprises et un plan de sauvetage a pu
être mis en place le 4 octobre 2016 ce
plan prévoyait un volet local avec
l'investissement des collectivités
territoriales pour l'électrification
d'une ligne permettant élevé d'arriver
directement sur le site de belfort
faisant ainsi du site
le centre européenne maintenance des tgv
et pérennise ans 150 emplois cette
convention était signée hier en présence
du préfet et des collectivités
territoriales
mais ce plan de sauvetage prévoyait
également un volet national avec des
investissements nouveaux pour
diversifier le site lachal case rames
tgv
en plus des six prévus pour le paris
turin et milan et l'achat par la sncf de
20 locomotives diesel or un grand
quotidien national d'économie a publié
une note interne de bercy remettant en
cause le plan de commande des tgv
le gouvernement s'est engagé et nous ne
pouvons pas croire que la parole donnée
ne sera pas respectée pouvez vous nous
dire monsieur le ministre
quand seront passés les commandes de tgv
par la sncf et où en est l'achat des
rames tgv par l'état je vous remercie
merci la parole est un monsieur
christophe sirugue secrétaire d'état
chargé de l'industrie
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
damien meslot votre question fait suite
en effet à une publication dans la
presse hier présenté comme remettant en
cause l'engagement du gouvernement qui a
été pris pour la poursuite de l'activité
sur le site
ce tome belfort je vous confirme ici
devant la représentation nationale
l'engagement du gouvernement qui n'est
nullement remis en cause la note qui a
été diffusée est une note qui a donné
lieu à l'expertisé d'un scénario
scénario qui n'a pas été retenue par le
gouvernement puisque leur gouvernement
le gouvernement n'a jamais souhaité
acheter directement segas rames de tgv
mais passer par le contrat cadre de la
sncf comme cela a été présenté dès le
début de nos discussions
je veux donc vous assurer à la fois de
notre détermination est bien évidemment
de notre volonté de continuer à vous
associez vous pouvez monsieur le député
maire mais également les organisations
syndicales les autres collectivités
locales comme la région le département
l'agglomération à ce travail que nous
avons engagés ensemble dans le respect
des engagements qui ont été pris
je vous réunirez donc le 17 février
prochain et cette date avait été fixée
préalablement pour comme la dernière
fois faire le point sur ses engagements
et nous avons de ce point de vue un
dialogue permanent avec la sncf pour que
les choses soient enclenchées
conformément au calendrier que je vous
avais présenté la dernière fois et donc
je veux vous dire ici que ce qui nous
motive ce qui nous mobilise c'est de
pouvoir permettre que l'activité soit
maintenue sur le site alstom de belfort
et cette activité sera maintenue
monsieur le député je vous prie de le
croire merci monsieur le secrétaire
d'état la parole est un monsieur ary
chalus